die spd gremien haben gerade begonnen
das spd-präsidium das geheimste gremium
was ist bei der partei gibt das geäst
die umstrittene vorsitzende ist zu
beginn dieses dieses präsidiums auf
armin laschet losgegangen auf die union
und hat kritisiert das ist dort einen
anspruch gab überhaupt auf die
regierungsbildung das sei angesichts von
über 8 prozentpunkten verlust nicht in
ordnung sagt saskia esken und wir leben
ja dass parallel nur wenige kilometer
vom willy brandt haus entfernt im konrad
adenauer haus genau diese debatte tobt
um diesen regierungsanspruch den ist der
gestern gegeben hat armin asche das habe
ich vorhin berichtet hat das mehr oder
weniger wieder eingepackt aber
gleichzeitig hat michael kretschmer der
sachsen anhaltinische ministerpräsident
harte töne raus gehauen er hat gesagt
die grundqualität war falsch gestern
abend und er hat gesagt das gesicht der
wahlniederlage nach außen ist armin
laschet das gehöre dazu daraufhin hat
armin laschet gesagt das sei doch klar
aber er will sich halten er will drin
bleibt er will zwar nicht fraktionschef
werden das hat er auch in diesem gremium
klar gemacht aber er will
parteivorsitzender bleiben und es gibt
aussagen auch von olaf scholz die lese
ich einmal vor was er dort gerade genau
im präsidium gesagt hat olaf scholz hat
gesagt es war eine großartige leistung
wir haben gezeigt dass wir geschlossen
sind nicht nur in der führung sondern in
der ganzen partei die bürgerinnen haben
angeschaut ob das wirklich so ist das
haben sie gesehen wir haben es gelungen
ein zuversichtliches programm zu haben
ich möchte dass die spd die partei der
anstehenden modernisierung unseres
landes ist und dann hat er die punkte
genannt für die die spd gewählt worden
sei um dann zu formulieren wir wollen
eine ampel regierung bilden mit grünen
und fdp wir wollen eine koalition bilden
die positive ziele für die zukunft hat
munter es wird deutlich werden dass es
gut für deutschland ist klarer ansage
hier endlich kann man fast sagen weil
aber nicht sagen hinter verschlossenen
türen aber wir hören dass alle sky
zumindest merkt man dass die spd heute
morgen nach dem einen kater aufgewacht
ist und gesehen hat wir müssen ja immer
noch darum kämpfen dass wir dieses
kanzleramt bekommen das wird uns nicht
einfach geschenkt weil wir erster werden
und das ist jetzt das direkte geheime
aufeinandertreffen nur wenige kilometer
entfernt voneinander das
willy-brandt-haus hier in der
kreuzberg in der nähe und das konrad
adenauer haus am tiergarten us trend
nicht viel und die beiden gremien diese
beiden geheim gremien die hämmern
aufeinander los
[Musik]